[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue d'un point de
vue comme chaque fois nous allons
échanger des points de vue de
préférences contradictoires sur
l'actualité du jour et je vous propose
de découvrir tout de suite
le sommaire de cette émission nous
commencerons par le break site on nous
avait dit que c'était impossible et
pourtant ils l'ont fait en tout cas la
première ministre theresa may est
parvenu à un accord avec la commission
européenne un marché de dupes
eh bien on essaiera de répondre à cette
interrogation nous nous intéresserons
aussi au parti socialiste faut-il qu'ils
disparaissent on en est là puisque
l'action du tout savoir s'il peut ou non
mais si ce serait souhaitable pour cette
gauche de se réformer ou de repartir de
zéro nous parlerons aussi de laurent
wauquiez
c'est ce week end qu'a lieu l'élection
pour la présidence des républicains le
favori at il un piste ouverte devant lui
va-t-il réussir on essaiera aussi de
répondre à cette question et puis bien
sûr nous parlerons des deux gloires
nationales disparu cette semaine johnny
hallyday et jean d'ormesson à qui le
président de la république a rendu un
hommage solennel ce matin aux invalides
est ce qu'il symbolise l'union nationale
et gars nous allons le demander à nos
quatre invités que je vais vous
présenter tout de suite bonsoir laurence
de charette
vous êtes la direction de la rédaction
du figaro.fr bonsoir un jamin grange
pourquoi vous êtes président de dance ou
consulting et directeur général de
dentsu agissent france votre métier
c'est la communication numérique les
stratégies d' influence tout ce qui se
passe sur les réseaux sociaux et qu'on
ne voit pas forcément
bonsoir guillaume bernard bonsoir vous
êtes maître de conférences ali 16 c
directeur de collection aux presses
universitaires de france on est très
heureux de vous accueillir dans l'équipe
votre dernier livre la guerre à droite
aura bien lieu le mouvement dextrogyre
dextrogyre j'avais un mouvement vers la
droite
c'est bien ça c'est là le gonflement des
idées par la droite du spectre politique
donc le glissement des idéologies de la
droite vers la gauche et s'ils voulaient
en salle wrightbus c'était chez des
clubs où r c'est toujours cette équipe
bauer c'était publié l'année dernière et
hervé nathan directeur adjoint de la
rédaction de marianne est aussi avec
nous qu'on soit un bon soir et votre
couverture de cette semaine et avant ça
tombe bien parce qu'on est en accord
avec notre sujet les immortels pourquoi
ils sont la france avec naturellement
jean d'ormesson et johnny hallyday dont
on reparlera dans quelques minutes mais
pas avant de nous être intéressés aux
breaks site
et bien finalement ce n'est peut-être
pas si difficile que ça de sortir de
l'union européenne
en tout cas c'est ce que semble croire
les et admettre pardon l'accord trouvé
cette nuit entre la commission
européenne et le royaume uni le
président de la commission justement
très tôt ce matin à bruxelles se
réjouissait de cette situation écouter
jean claude juncker en attendant vous
avez dit on ne peut pas sortir de
l'union européenne
il ya un article qu'il prévoit l'article
50 mais finalement on ne mettra jamais
en oeuvre et puis finalement c'est pas
si compliqué je vous êtes le consensus
moi j'ai toujours pensé que c'était
possible donc je fais pour une fois
c'est vrai je trouve que c'est d'autant
plus possible que finalement les
européens malgré leurs promesses sont
très en deçà des engagements qu'ils
avaient pris si on prend les trois
éléments que le lac enfin les européens
les 27
ceux qui sont restés dans l'union
européenne avait mis comme condition au
fait de commencer à discuter vraiment
des escrocs relations futures avec la
grande bretagne les trois conditions la
dette parce que ce qui reste là pays le
reste à payer pour la grande bretagne
normalement c'était au moins soit ça
c'était au moins 50 milliards sans doute
60 et il y avait des estimations jusqu'à
sion là on est 10 à 40 milliards ça
pourrait ça pourrait suffire
donc ça signifie que éventuellement et
la sai on est totalement dans
l'ambiguïté va quand même que le
gouvernement nous assure que nous
contribuables
est-ce que c'est mal parler à la
première personne du pluriel que nous
contribuables ne seront pas notre poche
pour les contribuables britanniques
parce que c'est comme ça le problème
c'est sir est quelque chose que les
anglais ne paye pas c'est les autres qui
ont payé les français les allemands etc
la deuxième condition c'était un statut
vraiment bétonner pour les nationaux
européens qui restera en grande bretagne
pour le moment on a dit qu'il aura accès
au marché ultra qui aura pas de
discrimination mais on voudrait sera
plus quid par exemple du rapprochement
familial
les polonais les français et c'est
qu'ils sont allés immigrés il ya 5 10
ans et qu'ils disent mais maintenant je
dois bien ma famille suivent ils auront
le droit ou pas est ce que la règle là
oui ça aussi c'est une ambiguïté voilà
et la troisième chose c'est fait
l'irlande parce qu'il ya là on a quand
même je rappelle que tous les pays les
27 s'ils ont tous un droit de veto il
suffit qu'un pays disent non et tout ce
touche à tout est par terre pour
évidemment pour l'irlande
c'est vital de ne pas rétablir des
frontières pour le mans a dit oui la
seule chose qu'on va faire c'est que
dans les années qui viennent on
appliquera le droit européen des deux
côtés de la frontière mais en fait été
repoussée à plus tard donc en fait les
européens
à mon sens tu on craque et presqu'autant
que le gouvernement britannique était
proche de craquer parce que
effectivement theresa may on l'a vu dans
les épisodes précédents étaient proches
de sauter le premier ministre avec une
majorité il fallait trouver une solution
et d'une certaine manière les pour moi
les européens ont commencé à craquer et
je pense qu'ils vont craquer encore plus
fort quand on va commencer à discuter
des conditions réelles du statut futur
je vais pas faire un trop long tunnel
on va même et voilà et donc parce qu'il
y aura des forces très importante qui
diront bon écoutez vous êtes gentil mais
nous on veut pouvoir continuer à contrat
qu'on va faire du commerce librement à
commencer par les indh automobile
japonais une chose toutes les usines
d'automobiles britannique appartiennent
à des groupes continentaux les où ils
sont soit allemand en général allemand
der voort hier soir pessah pour vauxhall
donc de toutes façons on va voir chez
nous des gens qui vont dire mes foulées
laisser rentrer vous laisser rentrer
parce qu'on veut que nous sommes dans la
ville veut dire c'est que ce qui
concerne le marché unique c'est pas du
tout tranché parce que non mais je vais
laurence de charette y aura bien compris
le l'accord dit alors les bleus
royaume-uni sortira du marché unique
sauf si on n'arrive pas à trouver un
accord et dans ces cas là il pourrait y
rester
ce qui fait que dès du côté de l'irlande
en décomptant les irlandais du nord
parce que ils croient qu'ils vont sortir
puisqu'ils sont attachés au royaume uni
et les irlandais du sud qui sont un état
européen
la république d'irlande qui est dit mais
non pas du tout on va rester unis sur
cette question là aussi bien que sur la
question de la cour de justice
européenne
et c'est vrai que l'europe a fait ce
qu'elle sait faire une ambiguïté qui
permet de sortir par le haut ou par le
bas c'est pas très très bien ce qu'on a
établi là c'est pendant ces neuf mois
c'est peut-être c'est la volonté de
divorcer
on a parlé beaucoup de gros sous comme
souvent dans un divorce mais on n'a pas
du tout établi les modalités du divorce
et
il reste encore je pense beaucoup
d'écueils beaucoup de travail devant
nous mais devant nous je me place des
politiques me sortir de l'autre côté qui
ont regardé du côté des britanniques
en fait les anglais disait on va sortir
de l'union européenne parce que ça nous
coûte trop cher et finalement là si ça
leur coûte 40 50 55 milliards on sait
pas exactement
peut-être que les environs changer
d'avis finalement peut-être que tony
blair qui avait dit au figaro faudrait
peut-être voter l'aurait raison les
opinions publiques sont toujours très
versatile ça on le sait bien la seule
chose c'est que dans cette affaire
pendant la campagne sur leur éxito me
disais qu'il allait y avoir une de crise
économique sans précédent si jamais le
président était voté ensuite on faisait
dire maintenant qu'il était admis par
l'opinion publique ça n'allait jamais
réussir à se réaliser
il y aurait une crise diplomatique on
s'aperçoit que on arrive toujours à
sortir d'une situation alors plus ou
moins dème ça c'est clair
mais en l'occurrence très sincèrement
aujourd'hui on ne sait absolument pas
enfin moi en tout cas mais je suis
peut-être pas suffisamment c'est rude en
la matière mais je ne sais absolument
pas comment véritablement les choses
vont se passer
du point de vue de la politique je sais
bien que c'est le niveau 0 1 mais ça a
un impact ça je connais un peu mieux
ça a un impact par exemple sur les
élections de 2010 9 et sur la
composition des groupes politiques au
parlement européen je vous rappelle
qu'il ya deux partis politiques les
conservateurs et le you keep qui sont au
centre ils sont des fils dorsale de deux
groupes politiques au parlement européen
et donc le retrait du royaume uni
provoquera sans aucun doute une
recomposition des groupes au parlement
européen il a de ce point de vue là on
en est absolument pour le coup
absolument certain pour ce qui est des
modalités exactes je dirais du retrait
du royaume uni très sincèrement ce soir
on ne sait absolument pas précisément
comment les choses se faire on est
encore dans le brouillard mais on n'est
pas tombé dans le fossé en toile à
benjamin grange alors moi je suis pas
aussi critique que vous parce qu'on sait
que dans une négociation le temps
finalement n'est pas linéaire
et là on assiste finalement à une
stratégie des petits pas avec une
première étape qui peut être un accord
très partiels sur lequel comme vous
dites on sait pas grand chose et que le
reste finalement est encore immense mais
en tout cas c'est une c'est une première
étape est de dire qu'en termes de
communication de ce projet de divorce
il y en avait besoin parce que ça fait
des aides ça fait des mois que l'on dit
on travaille on travaille on travaille
sans aucun accord est finalement avec
même à un moment une forme de retour en
arrière possible ça mais mettez ça mais
été bloqué et là finalement c'est un
acte qui est une forme de cliquer anti
retour et il en valait la crédibilité de
jean claude juncker et de l'europe qui
était finalement la victime puisqu'elle
a pris acte de la décision anglaise et
donc il lui fallait finalement montré
que ça ça avance et donc en en
l'occurrence je pense que c'était une
première étape de communication cas
aussi dans cet état pourra faire pour
arriver dans cette étape lie avec la
volonté affichée pour cette première
étape de montrer aux opinions publiques
européennes continentales que toute
tentative de sortie se paierait le
maximum voilà et ça c'était un objectif
on est affichée notamment gouvernement
français pour brouillon pour dissuader
les autres pour bien montrer y compris
c'est un usage interne en france et a
montré par exemple à ceux qui auraient
aux électeurs par exemple du front
national et aboulaye quitter l'union
européenne ont regardé combien ça va
coûter et ben c'est ça c'était un des
objectifs de cette première étape la
deuxième une fois ça il en fallait
montrer que c'est que ça coûte cher
et ben moi je pense que la démonstration
n'est pas fait voilà oui au moins de
soins
ça veut dire parce qu'on y est heureux
mais parce que ça coûterait plus cher
d'en sortir que d'y rester et pas c'est
pas mon énorme c'est que effectivement
je t'écris les à l'europe telle qu'elle
est partie puni qu'il voulait c'est vrai
alors on se rend on souhaite la
bienvenue à tous les internautes qui
nous ont rejoints qui font des
commentaires comme toujours pertinent
sur laquelle laurence de charette vous
allez pouvoir réagir commentaire de joch
par exemple qui nous dit et bien
vivement le fric site tandis qu'hugo
gagneux nous dit c'est quand même une
faillite de l'europe le break si tu ne
vas qu'accélérer la dislocation du
royaume uni et exacerber les tentations
régionalistes c'est vrai lorsque il ya
les irlandais où on voit que ça commence
à chauffer il ya les causes qui se
dirait peut-être moi je resterai bien en
europe
il ya même londres qui disait que
j'aimerais bien avoir un statut un peu
dérogatoire
le royaume sera peut-être moins unis à
l'avenir oui alors le royaume sera
évidemment il ya un tas de portes se
sont ouvertes ou en tout cas
potentiellement et un tas de danger
s'agit train de danger en tout cas de
dislocation c'est vrai que les anglo
saxons affirme une volonté très forte
sur ce point ils ont obtenu gain de
cause ils ont montré ben on veut pas se
faire dicter nos lois on veut choisir
notre immigration là dessus alors c'est
une prime effectivement à l'affirmation
de la volonté
l'exemple catalan a montré que ça marche
pas toujours voilà alors paul nous dit
le général de gaulle était un
visionnaire
quand il manifestait sa désapprobation
d'incorporer l'angleterre dans l'europe
très heureux du break 6 points
d'exclamation finalement guillaume
herlin le général avait raison une fois
de plus nécessairement sur tous les
sujets bien là en l'occurrence sur sa
défiance vis-à-vis je dirais du royaume
uni est une chose qui évidemment doit
être prise en considération et qui
explique peut-être le fait que de toute
façon le brésil va fonctionner à la fin
c'est l' équilibre au sein du
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
parce que si la construction européenne
abouti un jour à l'établissement d'un
état fédéral ce n'est pas encore le glas
ça veut donc dire que le siège permanent
de la france le siège permanent du
royaume uni devraient fusionner avec le
break site ou moins je dirais les
etats-unis ont toujours deux alliés au
conseil de sécurité mais dont alors à
secor effectivement là on peut penser
qu'il ya des enjeux qui dépassent très
largement je dirais les simples opinions
publiques événements jeu et les enjeux
comment dire juridiques même si
naturellement ce qui explique le break
si tu sais ça c'est la volonté de
reprendre je dirais le contrôle de son
destin
du point de vue territorial et du point
de vue normatif hervé nathan est ce qu
on avait une idée de comment ça pourrait
encore durer cette histoire et ils ont
lieu à deux ans de supprimer a compris
un délai de deux ans supplémentaires
balzac aulas avait tracé pas forcément
très confortables ces terres où là donc
il reste un an données normalement il y
avait c'était un article 50 d une fois
déclenché ces deux c'était un délai de
deux ans apparemment 50 ce qui prévient
la sortie par le gal le voir garnements
britannique a dit j'ai décidé c'est la
noc nous avons décidé de sortir une vous
enclenchons le normalement un compte à
rebours de deux heures et donc il reste
à peu près une année
ok c'est bien compris il y aurait un
délai de deux ans supplémentaires
pendant lequel la grande bretagne
appliquerait toutes les règles du marché
unique sans avoir plus aucune un peu
plus personne dans les instances
décisionnaires de la de l'union
européenne aura plus de parlementaires
européens pour les élections de 2010 9
il n'y aurait plus il y aurait plus de
coolus rtt etc et aurait quand même à
mon avis encore beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de hauts fonctionnaires ou une
à bruxelles parce que des choses qui ont
su faire les britanniques c'est de bien
investir la commission européenne et
en fait il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
fonctionnaires ce qui explique un peu
aussi l'orientation lens
si on prend un peu de recul quand le
break site est arrivé ça a été un coup
de tonnerre et on se dit c'est peut-être
la fin de laurent parce qu'on craignait
qu'ils aient un effet domino serre que
le royaume uni sorte que derrière il ya
un succès une poussée des populistes aux
pays bas en france aussi avec les
élections présidentielles de 2017 et et
marine le pen qui aurait pu être
dangereuse même si elle n'était pas élue
pression la pluie finalement on a
l'impression que l'incendié est maîtrisé
en quelques secondes
en fait ce qu'on voit c'est que ça
rapporte chacun a son histoire et que
nous n'avons pas la même histoire c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui fait la difficulté de
l'europe et c'est paradoxalement ce qui
aujourd'hui maintient une forme de
cohésion enfin en tout cas bloc cette
espèce de contagion dont vous parler
parce que la problématique des anglais
n'est pas du tout la même que celle des
catalans des espagnols et la façon dont
probablement l'europe va ressurgir dans
notre débat électoral d'ici quelques
mois ne se posera pas non plus
complètement de la même façon enfin
quelques problématiques vont venir mais
on n'est pas dans le même cas de figure
l'europe ne va pas très bien mais quand
on se compare on se console disait ma
grand mère elle pour regarder le parti
socialiste français est elle s'aperçoit
que finalement son sort n'est pas si
difficile pardon pour cette transition
un peu laborieuse
c'est notre deuxième thème de la soirée
parti socialiste faut-il qu'ils
disparaissent la question est un peu
provocatrice mais c'est aussi un appel à
vous les internautes voter sur le
hashtag figaro live #primaires point de
vue tout attaché et répondez à cette
question si ça vous intéresse
faut-il que le ps disparaissent en tout
cas ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il est en
danger de mort c'est le dernier épisode
c'est la création par benoît hamon qui
était le candidat socialiste à
l'élection présidentielle de son parti
ou de son mouvement génération point s
est ce que le ps est en danger de mort
écouter ce qu'en disait frédérique
espagnac c'est une sénatrice socialiste
des pyrénées-atlantiques que pour être
précis et elle était hier matin
l'invitée d'yves thréard au talk le
figaro
ça peut vous faire de l'ombre au parti
socialiste ce mouvement générations ça
passe c'est pas une histoire d'hommes
c'est encore une histoire de division à
gauche
oui je crois que la gauche va déjà mal
et donc j'ai envie de dire en tout cas
on a besoin de rassemblement aujourd'hui
le parti socialiste peut mourir dans ces
conditions oui je pense
faut faire attention et
les internautes qui commencent à voter
c'est vous qui nous regarde et vous êtes
à peu près même très précisément 71% à
me dire oui il faut que le parti
socialiste dise ça est ce que ça vous
étonne aussi hervé nathan exactement est
ce que vous pensez souhaitable que
finalement est ce qu'on appelle un reset
en informatique c'est à dire on
recommence tout je pense qu'il faut
faire un reset mais il faut s'entendre
je pense que le courant socialiste les
candidats socialistes va perdurer
parce que il vient de très loin et en
fait je pense qui a encore un avenir
pour les idées qu'ils ont pour certaines
des idées qu'il porte en revanche qui
évidemment en train de dc dc le parti
socialiste qu'on a qui est né en 1971 au
congrès d'epinay
c'est ça qui meurt c'est pas le congrès
c'est pas le parti de jean jaurès qui
m'aurait c'est éventuellement la
destruction est peut-être la
transformation ensuite ultérieure de
cette forme particulière qu'a pris le
cap read socialisme avec ça
guidés par françois mitterrand en 1971
avec jean pierre chevènement que
derrière qui était le qui était
l'inspirateur ou idéologique avec un
essai mais il faut se rappeler quelque
chose ça qui est qui manque dans la dans
la réflexion des socialistes c'est que
ce parti là c'est fait s'est constitué
et financement 1071 tout ce qu' il était
sur un mouvement social puissant qui
venait dé ont été trois ans après mai
1968 et même des comptes des conflits
ouvriers etc qui était bien bien bien
qu'ils remontent à bien avant
et donc il y avait un vrai courant qui
portait le parti socialiste est l'erreur
un modèle fait madame et espagnac par
exemple c'est de considérer que le
socialisme peut exister en dehors de ça
voilà il je pense qu'il ne peut renaître
qu'avec un mouvement social
je pose d'un point de vue de guillaume
un internaute qui nous dit on peut se
dire que quand on ne représente plus
rien on n'a plus de légitimité et on
doit se réinventer
je me tourne vers un autre guillaume
pour savoir s'il est d'accord avec cette
assertion
vous savez tout le monde le sait le
parti socialiste a été comment dire
incohérence et dire qu'il a continué à
s'appeler socialiste en étant devenu
social démocrate donc par conséquent si
vous voulez
évident que l'étiquette ne fait pas la
nature réelle du parti et est la
conséquence est la conséquence on l'a vu
la dernière présidentielle il a été
siphonné d'un côté et de l'autre par le
social-libéral macron et par
effectivement le socialiste mélenchon
le problème pour le pour le parti
socialiste c'est que outre le score
qu'il a fait à la présidentielle il a
perdu les élections locales antérieures
c'est à dire qu'ils ne disposent plus je
dirais de du socialisme municipal qui
avait permis pendant des décennies au
parti socialiste à la force socialiste
de continuer à exister et et d'avoir je
dirais un réservoir de cadres bon donc
aujourd'hui la seule chance finalement
pour le parti socialiste me semble-t-il
de continuer à exister
c'est la division de la france insoumise
mais quand division entre les jacobins
aînés communautariste et si cette
division là perdure effectivement le
parti socialiste peut être espérait
renaître de ses cendres
imaginez si l'on imaginé c'est une
hypothèse d'école qui ont bien que vous
soyez élu premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste
avez vous eu potez vous supprimerez le
parti pour créer autre chose ou pas est
ce qu'il faut est ce qu'il faut faire
table rase aujourd'hui très sincèrement
les forces politiques telle qu'elle
existait avant la grande coalition macro
nien son ont du plomb dans l aile je
crois qu'effectivement il faut
recomposer aussi bien du côté droit de
macron que du côté gauche des macros
donc c'est oui au oui mais plutôt si on
a bien compris et hugo gagneux qui a
aussi un point de vue sur sur ce sujet
nous dit il faut que le ps se modernise
avec un leader comme malek boutih quand
en marche exposera l'espace centre
gauche se libérera et le clivage
gauche-droite renaîtra c'est ce qu'on
appelle de la prospective
benjamin gans alors
en fait je vais quasiment enfoncer le
clou puisqu'on a dans un sondage le 30
novembre dernier posé la question de
l'eau français et finalement ils sont
74% à considérer que le pronostic est
que le parti socialiste allait
disparaître le point nouveau c'est que
il sait aussi 63% des sympathisants de
gauche
alors ce qui est ce qui est frappant
c'est surtout que si on compare ça par
rapport à septembre 2016
juste après finalement la débâcle
électorale eh bien ils n'étaient que 63
% c'est-à-dire pratiquement 10 points de
moins à considérer que le parti
socialiste allait allait disparaître
alors quand on creuse derrière pourquoi
finalement on sait comment dire ce
pronostic est si important et bien c'est
on retrouve un certain nombre de
qualificatifs comme il n'a guère de
conviction il n'est pas proche des gens
il n'est pas adapté aux évolutions du
monde et il n'est même pas utile à la
vie politique
la bio éthique française et finalement
quand on a ce portrait là on pourrait
dire noir c'est noir
on pourrait reprendre aussi
sartre qui disait en 60 de la gauche
c'est un grand cadavre à la renverse
plus que ça où les verts se sont mis en
tout cas aujourd'hui on en est là donc
voilà bon on est proche de l'avis de
décès d'ailleurs nos internautes ne
changent pas d'avis sur toujours 70 % à
penser qu' il faut qu'ils disparaissent
et vous laurence de charette allez-vous
donner dst un peu d'espoir à nos
camarades même plus la rue solférino
puisqu'il l'a met en vente
vous avez bien sûr en tout cas de
proposer le poste de dirigeant parce
qu'il ya ces petits candidats
moi je suis pas tout à fait d'accord
avec avec un reina temps finalement
donc on voit qu'il n'ya pas de candidat
il n'y a pas deux il ya plus de sièges
c'est un appareil en déliquescence mais
pour ce qui est également de son projet
c'est pas très facile à déterminer il ya
un parti tiraillé enfin partie en tout
cas voilà des des représentants qui sont
tiraillés entre les sociaux-démocrates
et l'extrême gauche
et puis toute la polémique on a vu
renaître récemment qui sépare les islamo
gauchiste des véritables républicain et
finalement comment on doit ce qu'est ce
qui reste du quels sont les quelle est
la ligne directrice du ps qu'elle
devrait telle qu'elle devrait l'être
on s'y perd complètement alors machin
vite vous mangez vous transformer en
chasseur de tête j'ai voulu donner des
candidats possibles pour le poste de
premier secrétaire
vous allez me dire qu'est qui vous
paraît le plus le plus adapté alors on
commence par le seul pour l'instant des
candidats officiellement déclarés
luc carvounas quitte à un député il ya
aussi najat vallaud belkacem l'ancien
ministre l'ancien ministre comme ça
qu'on dit aujourd'hui de l'éducation
nationale qui semble très intéressé par
le job
bahia françois hollande cas pas
complètement disparu de la circulation
le lawrence parlais à l'instant de ce
débat sur l'islam bail à manuel valls
qui a pris des positions très fortes là
dessus c'est vrai qu'il est plus parti
socialiste vous avez réservé est ce
qu'ils pourraient y revenir
est-ce que vous avez un candidat idéal
non je dis là une certaine manière mais
je suis assez d'accord finalement
on se rejoint ses repas 3 je sais qu'il
faut que je pense qu'effectivement là il
n'y a plus aucun élan ou partie de vos
parti socialiste celui qui est né en
1931 après il ya pour moi la possibilité
philosophiquement le dire il y aura
toujours une idée socialiste et heures
peut-être qu'elle est en france a soumis
ce peut-être qu'effectivement la france
a soumis sera une une partie de la
recomposition de la gauche mais il n'y a
pas de possibilité de recomposer un
parti un parti qui soit une alternative
politique en dehors d'un mouvement
social qui lui porterait parce que c'est
faux et le on aurait tort de négliger ce
qui s'était passé en santé oms et parce
qu'il y avait un mouvement ascendant
sociale qui a porté et le parti
socialiste était le dépositaire
politiques des mouvements sociaux et
c'est ça qui l'a porté en 80 c'est grâce
à ce sera avec un slogan ça peut changer
la vie
et grâce à ça il avait une terrain gagné
bon et j'avais même bien tj avec des
tracts ni de sillonner le pc absence et
permet non mais l'étincelle c'est de se
dire oui une partie de vos idées vos
caméras vidéo mais justement le
positionnement d'avantagés politiques
oui mais comment la reconnaître d'accord
mais comment faisait le parti socialiste
de cette époque là pour siphonner une
partie des voix du parti communiste il
était le meilleur représentant des
luttes que le parti commis ce monsieur
ce n'est plus notamment les luttes des
femmes par exemple on prend la question
de la lutte pour le pur pour la
libéralisation de l'avortement c'est
parti socialiste et yvette roudy qui
était en tête et le parti est partie
comme ici il avait entraîné encore
jeannette vermeersch qui cinq années
plus tôt disait que jamais les
prolétaires ne serait d'accord pour
avorter c'était ça donc effectivement le
parti communiste et fait siphonné mais
parce que il y avait un mouvement social
il fallait répondre et le parti
communiste s'est fait prendre en défaut
on arrête on a des sueurs évoqué par la
roquette non ok mais je suis d'accord
mais surtout du laring charismatique
nous avoir entraîné ce que l'on soit
différent est ce que vous pouvez faire
correspondre le chaos un quelconque des
noms que vous avez cités là à la réponse
un problème profond de la société et à
peut-être manuel valls comme manuel à
ces partis chez les républicains marche
je trouve que là c'est un peu compliqué
mais il ya malek boutih hugo disait
malraux qui pourquoi pas qui est aussi
cas aussi des positions très fermes sur
le wiiware le refus du communautarisme
et fo après il faut être capable
d'élargir d'être le le col
l'homme qui représente ça et pas
seulement l'homme le programme
l'ambiguïté ça n'existait pas encore en
effet bastien qu'il existe l'ambiguïté
que vous avez évoqué c'est est-ce que
c'est l'idée socialiste mais ces idées
progressistes moteur effectivement
socialiste très sincèrement je pense que
une toute forme de collectivisme même
chez jaurès le collectivisme permettait
le maintien de propriété privée
aujourd'hui toute forme de collectivisme
je dirais et quand même a quand même peu
le vent en poupe et donc par conséquent
effectivement c'est plutôt le
progressisme et dans ce cas là c'est
gilbert annette et bacon la carnation l'
écart n'est donc effective alors il est
peut-être pas de possibilité mais voilà
un message personnel pour josh qui nous
dit moi je veux bien être président du
ps s'il cherche c'est bien je chante à
envoyer votre candidature sans faute au
siège du parti une fois qu'on aura
trouvé où il est benjamin gans alors
dans le jeu de trouver les leaders on
avait posé une question qui était de
dire toujours le 30 novembre
laquelle de ces personnalités souhaitez
vous représentez sauter ou qu'elle
représente la gauche aux prochaines
élections de 2022 alors à 34% les
sympathisants de gauche on avait benoît
hamon bon on a vu effectivement que il
avait voilà transit parti ensuite vient
arnaud montebourg 19 % et nadja tu
deviens qui en 16 % manuel valls 13% et
stéphane le foll 8%
donc en fait on voit bien à travers 5 il
y en a aucun des grands leaders qui se
dégage en tout cas des leaders restant
guillaume naudi les classes populaires
et ouvrières socle de l'électorat ps pc
ont disparu en france en poids
démographique c'est vrai que ça peut
être une explication et hugo nous dit
sinon pourquoi pas une union avec le
nouveau parti radical avec mon avis
c'est le la porte qu'elle est c'est la
vallasse et le chemin tout tracé vers le
vert l'elysée laurence de charette quand
on voit la structure de popularité de
d'emmanuel macro on s'aperçoit qu'en
fait il est plus populaire à droite qu'à
gauche peut-être que ça ça pourrait
rouvrir un espace non au parti
socialiste
quand on voit ce président qui supprime
l'impôt sur la fortune qui libéralise le
code du travail qui fait l'éloge de jean
d'ormesson une sauce sur la pierre
attention sur les blocs c'est quand même
une certaine catégorie de riches mais
pas tous mais mais lorsqu'on pensait que
ça va avec un maquereau qui sont plutôt
de droite en tout cas en économie ça
pourrait redonner de l'oxygène à un
futur parti socialiste alors
paradoxalement c'est ce consiste à dire
finalement
les médias mâcon s'est fait élire avec
un programme qui n'était pas aussi
affirmé sur le point de vue libéral
économique est finalement là dessus
chacune des positions qui prend avance
de plus en plus et grignote tout le
terrain de wauquiez et paradoxalement
sur les questions sociétales
il est plus à gauche mais ces questions
sociétales étant des gens a déjà
représenté
il reste plus que najat vallaud belkacem
qui pour elle est sur représentée à
gauche qui pourrait être plus
provocatrice allait peut-être plus loin
si on voulait laisser au parti
socialiste
si on cherche un boulot parti socialiste
puisque c'est ça qu'on lui cherche des
candidats auditionnés visionnement et
j'avoue que je peine à vonnas temps ce
pourrait être un finalement 1,1 à liés à
la reconstruction du ps emmanuel ma
croix par sa politique économique un peu
libérale en tout cas c'est pas
l'impression qu'ils n'ont plutôt
l'impression qui va à la pêche il n'a
pris là non il
si on veut parler comme sa tactique
politicienne impression que ces
stratégies casse-noisette on va
peut-être d'ici l'été des élections
européennes bientôt mais et élections
européennes on voit bien que les l'idée
c'est que yes et 2c de détruire tout ce
qu'il ya entre la république en marche
et la france est soumise à côté puis de
l'autre côté il ya la symétrie entre
avec le front national
donc je pense l'allier en tout cas ses
mails ses baisers du cycle chercheurs
l'expression je vais d'abord celle de
l'église et à la charte que vous n'êtes
pas très optimiste pour l'avenir du
parti socialiste est-ce que ça a fait
changer d'avis les internautes ou est-ce
qu'on est toujours à 70%
et bien non ça reste 70 % donc la sphère
est fait et nous allons pouvoir passer
de l'autre côté de l'échiquier politique
pour nous intéresser aux républicains
c'est
ce week-end de l'élection à la
présidence de ce parti uniquement pour
les membres des républicains les
adhérents qui vont qui vont voter
laurent wauquiez est le grand favori
pour autant il ne fait pas l'unanimité
au sein de son parti
écoutez la dernière méchanceté en date
c'est celle de jean louis debré
président du conseil constitutionnel
il était ce matin sur france info et il
hésite et a décerné à laurent wauquiez
un brevet de gaullisme
regardez moi je suis profondément
gaulliste comme jean d'ormesson était
gaulliste ou alors en vo qui grille qui
les gaullistes c'est possible mais je
n'ai jamais vu avant voilà avec des avec
des amis comme ça on n'a plus besoin
d'ennemis
guillaume bernad le positionnement de
laurent wauquiez est ce qu il est aussi
clair que le reproche que lui font ses
adversaires c'est à dire il est à droite
toute
il est certain que dans son discours
personnel et dans l'attitude qu'il a on
l'a vu par exemple avec la sphère des
crèches
il assume une position droite hier donc
je dirais il vise évidemment les
militants les sympathisants du parti
pour avoir un soutien un soutien
populaire
on sait bien que la base d'un parti
politique est toujours plus à droite que
les caciques je dirais bon mais d'un
autre côté évidemment laurent wauquiez
il a besoin je dirais pour essayer de
maintenir le restant d'unité du parti va
d'avoir des alliés pour essayer de
d'éviter je dirais une destruction donc
il ya virginie calmels s'il y avait au
foyer ce biais voilà qui évidemment sont
je dirais bd des moyens d'être un peu
dans une position attrape tout donc
c'est vrai que c'est une position
inconfortable puisque c'est le grand
écart c'est à la fois je dirais avoir le
soutien de la base par un discours
droitier mais en même temps essayer de
maintenir l'unité de l'appareil on peut
penser que à l'avenir lorsqu'il va
s'agir non pas simplement de désigner un
un patron du parti mais il va falloir
désigné déterminer un programme un
positionnement établir des listes pour
les élections par exemple les élections
européennes est là pour le coup les les
grands du parti vont évidemment essayer
de je dirais de l'attendre au coin de au
coin de la rue donc c'est vrai que
vraisemblablement à votre question oui
il devrait gagner parce que ses
concurrents à la présidence de l air son
jeu
ir est certes je dirais intéressant mais
non pas la visibilité qu'il qui la met
en revanche ça ne veut pas dire qu'il va
pouvoir contrôler véritablement
l'appareil et en faire ce qu'ils le
désirent alors vous êtes invités à
répondre à cette question
wauquiez va-t-il réussir tant que sur le
hashtag fear alive acheter un point de
vue point de vue au pluriel tout attaché
pour l'instant 49% des
internautes disent non évoquées ne va
pas réussi non pas penser ça ses 49% qui
dit oui il va réussir ça c'est mon côté
optimiste et 51% qui disent non il va
pas réussir pour comprendre un petit peu
plus ce qu'est l'état d'esprit des
électeurs de droite
nous avons fait notre sondage
hebdomadaire avec nos amis de doxa et
benjamin c'est vous qui allez nous le
commenter quels sont les enseignements
de ce sondage
alors en fait quand on interroge les
sympathisants et l'air c'est un petit
peu plus que les internautes
d'aujourd'hui puisque ils sont 62% à
considérer que s'il était adhérent et
bien laurent wauquiez il voterait pour
laurent wauquiez
laurent wauquiez qui sort évidemment
comme comme un grand favori mais on est
on s'achemine plutôt vers une victoire
qu'on pourrait qualifier à la pyrrhus
parce que cette large domination elle
doit être relativisée relativiser parce
que durant sa campagne
finalement il a perdu du terrain si on
compare finalement sa cote de popularité
auprès des sympathisants à l'air et bien
elle a perdu 16 points en deux mois
et puis ensuite évidemment terme de
notoriété il est face à des compétiteurs
qui sont beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
moins connu et donc il ya une prime pour
lui alors le deuxième point qui est
important est de c'est le deuxième
enseignement c'est quand on creuse
finalement l'image en détail du futur
patron des républicains
hélas hélas on voit que il ya une
majorité de français est d'ailleurs bon
nombre de sympathisants et l'eire qui ne
le trouvent ni honnête à 60%
li sympathique à 55 ni proche des gens à
62% et donc
forcément ça pose question alors on
s'est mis à creuser les choses alors si
la régie peut nous mettre ce que on a
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est de
regarder
finalement ce qu'on en dit et donc vous
avez sur cette voie là sur cette
cartographie vous savez ces petites
icônes qui donne un peu les sentiments
et alors il y en a deux qui sont qui
sont amusants donc le pool premier amusé
en tout cas le premier qui ressort c'est
finalement cette flèche en bas qui
clairement veux mentionner que c'est pas
très intéressant le débat mais le
deuxième est plus intéressant c'est le
deuxième qui ressort c'est le pinocchio
et ça illustre finalement voilà toute
cette perception de pas forcément de
très grandes de très grande honnêteté
pour l'heure encore qu'est ce qu'ils
écoutent
comment dire c'est mieux qu'au ps oui on
voit que c'est pas c'est pas gagné à
passer le premier tour enfin son
élection est en quasi assuré son job
n'ait pas gagné moi il reste beaucoup de
travail et c'est d'autant plus difficile
que son son premier job on va dire c'est
d'être de reconquérir les lettres de
premiers opposants mais ça emmanuel
macron est pas prêt à laisser faire
parce qu'il n'y a vraiment aucun intérêt
mélenchon était un opposant parfait
d'abord parce qu'il est quand même moins
crédible on peut faire ce plaisir
ok et deuxièmement parce qu'il a le
grand mérite d'expliquer aux électeurs
de droite que macro est bien plus
intéressant que wauquiez alors tout ça
c'est un piège et commanditaires je
pense ce piège va continuer à agir pour
les européennes le mois de mai at il
nous a rejoint du figaro.fr bonsoir mr
bah alors vous êtes allez vous plonger
sur les dents les réseaux sociaux est ce
que vous confirmez
cette spécialité un peu critique dont
nous parlait benjamin ou pas il
confirmera pour le coup je suis allé
dans les commentaires sous le sondage du
jour est donc dans les commentaires il
ya deux communautés qui s'affrontent ce
sont ceux qui croient en laurent
wauquiez pour dimanche 6 à lure il y
arrivera est ce qu'il trouve stupide
justement ceux qui pensent qu'il va
relever le niveau
alors on a notamment au fbi qui nous dit
ce qui se dit ou s'écrit sur wauquiez
est ahurissant cela fait des mois que
les candidats de droite qui ont tous
échoué directement ou par jeunes
candidats interposés temps de dézinguer
le favori c'est pitoyable
la jalousie transpire de leurs propos
dans la même veine on aille à l
478 qui nous dit je suis de droite
classique et je ne comprends pas
l'avalanche de critiques qui tombe sur
wauquiez proches du fn
je ne le crois pas si parler d'identité
nationale est réservé au front national
il faut nous le dire
est il proche de sens commun si un
mouvement chrétien qu'on se constitue un
problème pour l r j'en tirerai les
conséquences qui s'imposent
josé maria qui nous dit laurent wauquiez
incarne l'espoir tangibles pour plus de
14 millions de retraités qui sont
maltraités fiscalement par macro partout
où je vais annie connaissance on ne
parle plus que de wauquiez en termes
élogieux dommage de devoir vieillir de
quatre ans de plus avant de voir la
lumière et de pouvoir souffler un peu
et enfin on a les autres notamment gaby
grain de sel qui nous dit je suis de
droite classique et je coince avec
wauquiez c'est un personnage
remarquablement intelligent mais qui
n'inspire ni confiance ni amitié il sera
lui aussi uniquement jugés sur son bilan
mais je doute de sa capacité à incarner
la france comme président et enfin jean
claude baillet qui nous dit gêné d'être
habitant lyon avec cette personne comme
président de région
que fait-il pas grand chose rien il me
fait penser à trump
il devient boss des républicains je lui
envoie ma carte vieille de 25 ans enfin
si il a même destin présidentiel que
trump
après tout il ya peut-être une stratégie
hervé nathan oui c'est vrai que la
difficulté qu'on voit laurent wauquiez
c'est de sortir du personnage qui s'est
construit lui-même c'est quand on fait
quand on voit le parcours de convoquer
et quand même quelqu'un qui commet chez
les démocrates chrétiens et qui
maintenant est en train d'en tout cas
apparemment de flirter avec le front
national
donc c'est ainsi qu'un personnel fin
apparemment on dira c'est à moi de
répondre d'accord avec vous on vous
donnera la parole après
voilà donc on verra pour le moment là sa
stratégie sans minorer de toute façon
les chances sont de son camp d'arriver
un jour au gouvernement
je pense que d'une certaine manière
c'est ce que cherche on me disait ce que
cherchent les maquereaux niasse et le
repousse et de ce côté là et que pour le
moment il a l'air de trouver normal
trouvé de trouver cette voie comme la
voix lui la voix de sa chance je j'ai du
mal quoi guillaume bernard oui je
réagissais là sur la question de la
proximité avec le front national
il a dès juillet dernier donc après les
législatives pris une position alors que
d'ailleurs personne ne le lui demandait
pris une position extrêmement claire sur
le fait qu' il adoubé plus la stratégie
du ni ni
mais qu'il voulait à tout prix
réinstaller le cordon sanitaire jerry
sloan et nice était en uniforme accro à
l'information juste après avoir dit qu
au moment des échéances et au moment où
on voit quelle est la même politique
c'est un moment lui pose des questions
monsieur monsieur évoqué entre entre
entre monsieur macro et madame le pen
que vous choisissez vous il dit ne
choisit pas appris après il ya ce but
quand même il aurait fallu que je
choisisse meilleur pour un pur quand on
prétend à la plus haute fonction de
l'état et avoir le doigt sur beuvron
nucléaire je pense qu'il vaut mieux
avoir plus de caractère que ça et on a
en tout cas le montrer aux électeurs que
ça c'est quelque chose dont on se
souvient ça c'est peut-être mieux c'est
donc dire que des personnalités non vous
pouvez pas dire c'est que la question de
la proximité entre vaud qui est le front
national du foyer des idées pouvaient
pas prétendre que ça ne se pose pas
comme questions politiques alors ça en
je suis d'accord c'est à dire que
électoralement parlant il refuse toute
alliance mais en revanche ils
développent plus ou moins une stratégie
à la ligne buisson
c'est à dire une droitisation de son
propre discours pour essayer
effectivement de 2 comment dire de
capter un électorat à terme qui est un
électorat qui est déçu du front national
et essayer effectivement de reconstituer
une de droite je dirais à son profit le
problème c'est qu'on en a parlé tout à
l'heure le ps est je dirais écartelée
entre la france insoumise et macro et l
air le risque aujourd'hui c'est qu'il
soit en revanche écrasé entre maquereau
et le front national parce qu'évidemment
les prochaines échéances électorales
ce sont les européennes et la même si
marine le pen est décrédibilisé du point
de vue de sa propre personne il est
certain que le dit
pour eurosceptiques du front national et
arrive en bloc
tandis qu évidemment et l'air est
parfaitement divisés sur cette position
est donc vous imaginez une liste
nationale l air aux européennes avec un
souverainiste un fédéralisme
eurosceptique et c'est ça va ne
ressemblait à rien donc c'est évidemment
ça la très grande difficulté que
lectorat et donc l'électorat du front
national est raboté front national et ce
qu'ils euros oui on va voir peut-être eu
un dernier une dernière question de
notre sondage aux ducks à benjamin
grange et peut-être qu'il remontera un
peu le moral de laurent wauquiez
quand même c'est pas le plus mauvais
candidat aux yeux des électeurs de
droite pas pour la présidence des
républicains mais pour celle d'après
celle de 2022 la présidentielle oui
alors finissons sur une sur une note
positive pour laurent wauquiez quand on
leur pose la question et c'est quel est
le meilleur candidat évidemment les
sympathisants qui le rendirent pour 2022
les sympathisants républicains disent à
34% évidemment laurent wauquiez on sent
quand même derrière qu'il ya une envie
d'avoir un leader qui va incarner ce ce
parti-là et et xavier bertrand du côté
des sympathisants républicains à rivka
23% alors effectivement l'ordre ce qu'on
dit est un tout petit peu différente on
regarde l'ensemble des français mais à
ce stade il n'y a pas grand chose à en
dire
toujours pour compte pour eux pour
terminer sur cette note positive
il ya quand même deux choses qui sont à
porter au crédit long terme d'image de
laurent wauquiez c'est que les
sympathisants les français lui
reconnaissent qu'il est dynamique
pour 58% d'entre eux ayant des
convictions pour 50% 55% montre donc la
tâche est importante mais en même temps
il a plein de qualités sur lequel il
faut compter
merci benjamin grand je vous propose
maintenant de nous intéresser à deux
personnalités que nous aimions beaucoup
je pense qu'on peut le dire je sais pas
si c'est collectif en tout cas au figaro
qui sont jean d'ormesson et johnny
hallyday je vous remonte la couverture
de marianne s'il est encore possible de
la voir qui les associe tous les deux en
dix ans les immortels pourquoi ils sont
là france hervé nathan vous y allez pas
de main morte là c'est la fois la france
c'est johnny hallyday jean d'ormesson
c'est un ils méritent tous les deux un
hommage national on a décimé on a décidé
de plonger toute fin de l'est
nous quoi comme quand il y avait une
concordance des temps on peut pas le
cacher donc deux jours d'intervalle qui
sont voilà donc il y avait on a eu envie
de dire deux choses la première c'est
que comme la france quand même si la
littérature est certaine manière jean
d'ormesson représentait bien la
littérature française alors je n'irais
pas jusqu'à dire que c'était victor hugo
je pense que il faut essayer aussi
éviter des exagérations et rahmane on
verra ça ça se verra dans 50 ans je
crois que chez nous on dit qu'il ya un
des collègues de jean d'ormesson qui dit
c'est et victor hugo ou oui mais sont
les misérables ni les travailleurs de la
mer donc ça commence pas facilement mais
c'était quand même une image de
littérature c'est vrai que la france que
les français se reconnaissent dans la
littérature si voilà c'est la une c'est
une s'il y avait eu une d âme une âme à
la france et littérature fait partie
jean et quant à quentin johnny hallyday
d'une certaine manière il nous
représente tous parce que chacun il a eu
sa vie a été tellement compliqué
complexe sa vie d'artiste et sa vie
personnelle qu'une certaine manière elle
a touché tous les français les uns après
les autres voire concomitamment faut
quand même se souvient juste revenir
tout odile tout au début c'est cesson a
presque oublié mais c'était l'hymne
c'était quasiment l'image du diable pour
la france bien pensante
c'était l'image des blousons noirs c'est
le concert de la nation qui finit en
émeut et ses intérêts puis petit à petit
il a élargi totalement sont ils à utile
et alegre son service mais il est allé
faire son service qualité voilà
sympathie qui était l'icône de la
conception aurait pu être l'icône une
contestation prolétarienne extrêmement
radical au tout début est devenu petit à
petit l'ami de nicolas sarkozy d'abord
de jacques chirac avant lui il a passé à
droite et donc d'une certaine manière
voilà c'est un parcours politique et
artistique qui finit par toucher
l'ensemble de la population ce qui fait
que demain matin j'imagine le match sera
sûrement très humour donc à cette
question à laquelle nous vous proposons
aussi de répondre
johnny hallyday jean d'ormesson enfin
l'union nationale pas l'interrogation
est bien hervé nathan répond oui vous
aussi vous pouvez répondre hashtag
figaro live #primaires vue il y aurait
un autre qui est d'acord sur cette
unanimité autour des deux hommes et bien
c'est jean louis debré
l'ex président du conseil
constitutionnel qu'on a entendu à
l'instant et convard et entendre c'était
ce matin sur france info
mais selon d'unanimité
soyons heureux de rendre cet hommage
alors al je nie ou à jean d'ormesson la
nation a toujours rendu des hommages à
des grands personnages je pense à paul
valéry
je pense à à maurice barrès je pense à
la première femme qui a eu des obsèques
nationales qui était colette en 1954 au
palais royal
oui il est bien une nation c'est un rêve
d'avenir partager mais c'est aussi une
histoire
alors pour l'instant 71% les internautes
répondent plutôt non à cette question
twitter sur l'union nationale guillaume
bernard ce matin j'assistais comme
beaucoup de gens du figaro à l'hommage
rendu par le président république à jean
d'ormesson dans la cour des invalides
il y avait ces honneurs militaires ce
drapeau bleu blanc rouge sur le cercueil
est ce que on aurait dû faire la même
chose pour pour johnny hallyday ou
est-ce que vous voyez une différence de
nature entre eux entre ces deux parcours
cc c'est bien difficile comme question
honnêtement parce que ça laisserait
supposer qu'il faudrait guérard chizé la
valeur des hommes
et ça j'avoue que je n'oserais pas à
prendre position moi ce qui me vide
amant la situation je dirai où il ya une
certaine unanimité est extrêmement
touchante jeu j'ai plutôt quand même
tendance à penser qu' il y a j'espère
qu'il n'y aura pas demain je dirais des
scènes d'hystérie mais qu' il ya généré
une disproportion peut-être entre je
dirais la mort de deux personnes
parfaitement honorable et dont l'oeuvre
est intéressante et je dirais le comment
dire le l'hommage national sous les là
je vais vraiment passer pour un pur
comment dire pour un vieux rabougris
mais que voulez vous aussi voulez pour
moi l'unité de la nation
l'élu pour moi l'unité de la nation c
c'est philippe auguste qui met la pâtée
à jean sans terre à bouvines pour moi
c'est condé qui met la pâtée aux
espagnols à rocroi
voilà ça pour moi évidemment ça a un
sens c'est à dire que c'est évidemment
bon alors cela dit ce qui est très
touchant c'est que incontestablement et
part je dirais une culture plutôt
intellectuelle pour jean d'ormesson et
pour une culture populaire pour johnny
hallyday
et il ya quand même dans ces deux
personnages là je dirais le signe qu'il
y à une appartenance à une culture
commune et donc là de ce point de vue là
évidemment c'est quand même quelque
chose d'important de ce que bien on se
rend compte que avec pourtant des
divisions sociales avec des divisions
politiques avec des opinions je dirais
diverses
il y a quand même je dirais une
appartenance nationale qui est réel
parce que il y à la communion dans une
même culture
pour autant est-ce qu'il faut porter aux
nues nécessairement autant qu'on le fait
je dirais de personnalités intéressantes
je suis peut-être un peu dubitatif eh
bien vous avez un allié en la personne
de jackson qui nous dit ne soyons pas
superficiel l'union nationale sur ce
deux décès c'est ridicule comme idée
laurence de charette est ce que vous
serez sur les champs-elysées demain
matin en fait je pense qu'il faut pas
passer ça saoule pas sûr que ce genre
terme d'union nationale puisque c'est un
terme qu'un dimension politique or je
pense qu'on est plutôt dans une autre
dimension qui est plutôt de l'ordre de
l'essentialité comment
jean d'ormesson disait ben il faut pas
mourir le même jour copia parce que la
presse est comme cocteau on s'est fait
mettre de côté et là je crois que c'est
exactement l'inversé on assiste à une
semaine un peu extraordinaire où malgré
tout ces deux stars au lieu de se manger
la lumière l'une ou l'autre cela renvoie
qu'est ce qu'on a fait toute la semaine
on a parlé de générosité on a parlé de
vérité on a parlé de culture de rock et
c est en réalité c'est cette ode comme
un commune à des valeurs autour du rock
et de la littérature tôt douze audace et
improbable nous renvoie malgré tout à
une essence française est d'ailleurs
macron a dit aujourd'hui ben la
littérature c'est l'essence de la france
donc on arrive dans une forme
d'universalité qui est normalement le
propre de l'art et peut-être de l'esprit
français et demain matin dès 10 heures
lefigaro.fr retransmettra en direct
nous y serons et lily qui dit à
l'instant c'est joli ce que dit laurence
mais oui c'est très vrai benjamins alors
moi je me suis je me suis intéressé à
voir comment les médias finalement
relaté heure-là tfc hommage alors on se
confronteront peut-être peut-être à tort
sur sur johnny hallyday puisque c'est là
qu'est le plus de volume et finalement
il ya deux choses deux choses qui
ressorte la première c'est que j'ai
regardé les audiences télé parce que
finalement tout le monde a bousculé ses
programmes pour faire des émissions
spéciales et il se trouve que ça n'a pas
fait recette puisque les audiences ont
été souvent inférieure à un programme
originel
la deuxième chose c'est de regarder
comment cet hommage populaire c'est
s'est opéré sur les réseaux sociaux
et c'est là qu'on voit finalement
comment le lait français utilise ce
pouvoir de résonance parce que le
conduire le tweet qui a été le plus
partagé sur johnny hallyday c'est le
tweet d'un d'un artiste d'un chanteur
qui s'appelle sheeran qui a sonné en
dire je suis triste c'est tout et qui a
été qu'ils étaient à briller ces gens là
sans briller la sobriété la sobriété le
deuxième c'est évidemment celui du
président maquereau et le troisième
c'est celui d'un inconnu
comme quoi on peut arriver aussi à être
en résonance
même quand on n'est pas connu c'est pour
retrouver le meilleur de ces deux
personnalités
je vous signale le hors série du figaro
magazine consacré à johnny hallyday qui
est dans les kiosques et ans vous allez
voir à l'instant la couverture quant à
nous au figaro magazine et bien nous
avons voulu rendre hommage à jean
d'ormesson qui a été pendant 16 ans le
chroniqueur du fig mag
chaque semaine avec un adieu à ses
personnels avec des témoignages de
frédéric beigbeder le critique
littéraire du fig mag de philippe
bouvard ou d'eric neuhoff et vous hervé
nathan est ce que vous serez tellement
matin sur les champs-elysées
je ne pense pas que je serai sur les
champs-elysées pour des raisons
personnelles mais je pense qu'il faut
pop art faut pas négliger l'émotion
d'une partie au moins deux
de la population qui est causé par le
décès de johnny hallyday je pense que il
ya quelque chose qui tout d'un coup à
s'effacer lisions parce que d'une
certaine manière il ya toute une
génération c on a parlé beaucoup la
génération baby boom et qui
effectivement est en train de sortir de
la scène politique mais n'empêche que
c'est entièrement reconnu entièrement le
vécu avec avec johnny hallyday
je rappelle quelque chose de rose soupe
ça s était dit non non et non les
différents articles ont été publiés par
les journaux mais dans il ya une
génération qui à écouter johnny hallyday
tous les soirs sur sûre cependant dans
salut les copains sur europe 1 tous les
soirs et la moitié des jeunes la mouette
il faut quand même se réduire parce que
c'était la moitié les jeunes avaient
l'oreille collée au transistor à 17h
pour écouter l'émission delfini pas qui
sait une chose c'est une communion que
effectivement on retrouve cinquante ans
plus tard transformé différentes mais
c'est celle là aussi qu'on retrouve et
du statut maya à cette nostalgie delà
d'un paradis perdu qui était le pari de
cette jeunesse là donc c'est un peu là
une génération entière mais qui a compté
comme dans l'histoire de ce pays qui
compte ans et qui pèse encore même
dorique économiquement moins que c'est
des retraités et qui pèse encore mais
qui avait voilà qui a du poids qui d'une
certaine manière l'impression a fait
aussi des soirées pays parce que c'est
la matérialisation de la transformation
alors malheureusement point de vue c'est
fini pour ce soir je le regrette parce
qu'on a deux commentaires passionnants
sur lesquels on aurait pu réagir mais
tant pis je vous laisse à votre talent
je les laisse pardon à votre réflexion
jax man qui dit ce qui m'attriste c'est
la manière avec laquelle le pouvoir
exploitent ces deux décès était-il
vraiment nécessaire que brigitte macron
haïti johnny pour l'interrogation
et puis renard 83 sur twitter qui nous
dit quelque chose avec lequel je suis
pas d'accord mais c'est pas pour ça que
c'est pas intéressant de deux mondes
différents il y a d'un côté les gens du
système qui admire d'ormesson et de
l'autre les pauvres qui a nui à johnny
je suis pas sûr que les riches n'aime
pas aussi johnny hallyday mais merci
renard 83 de nous avoir donné votre
point de vue j'ai un dernier rendez vous
à vous donner c'est mardi prochain 12
décembre
il reste quelques places salle gaveau
pour les rencontres du figaro qui se
dérouleront avec l'historien franck
ferrand et si vous avez encore une toute
petite hésitation pour savoir si vous
prenez votre place et bien je vous
invite à regarder ce qui suit dans
quelques instants sur figaro live merci
beaucoup à tous les quatre et bon
week-end
[Musique]